Transcription: eric vautier
« Moi, j’ai buté mon patron.
Mais c’était un con.
Puis maintenant j’ai payé,
alors je veux me réinsérer. »
C’est dans ce silence glacial
que Joseph me regarde droit dans les yeux
pour commencer son entretien d’embauche.
Moi, je suis interloqué, effrayé.
Je me questionne :
« Son patron était-il vraiment un con ?
Et moi, en suis-je un ?
Est-ce moral ?
Qu’est-ce que je risque ?
A-t-il payé sa dette ? »
Joseph m'explique son parcours,
ses motivations.
Moi, j’ai besoin de main-d’œuvre.
Je n'ose pas lui dire non.
Joseph est un grand gaillard,
tout de cuir habillé,
tatoué du bout des doigts jusqu’au front.
La voix rauque et autoritaire, il vient
de purger une longue peine de prison.
Je prends le risque de lui donner
sa chance et je l'embauche.
J'ai découvert un homme, certes un peu
brut de décoffrage, mais très attachant,
hyper motivé et assumant son parcours.
Nous sommes le 12 janvier 2005
et Joseph a changé beaucoup de choses
dans ma façon de gérer l’entreprise.
Je m’appelle Olivier Riom, j’ai 55 ans
et je dirige une entreprise de bâtiment.
Nous concevons et réalisons
des aménagements de bureaux,
dans le Grand Ouest,
avec 50 collaborateurs.
Depuis Joseph, il y a 17 ans,
nous avons accompagné une centaine
de personnes éloignées de l’emploi,
des personnes qui sortent du milieu
carcéral, des gens du voyage,
des personnes ayant connu la galère
de la rue et des migrants.
Si nous avons recruté ces personnes,
c’était au début une piste
pour avoir de la main-d’œuvre.
Mais si nous avons continué
dans cette démarche,
c’est que ça donne du sens à notre projet
parce que je suis persuadé
que l’entreprise est
un acteur majeur d’intégration
et que nous prenons du plaisir
à prendre soin des autres.
Je vais parler
des compagnons de l’entreprise.
C’est le nom que nous donnons aux ouvriers
par respect pour leur professionnalisme,
leur implication
et la technicité du métier.
Lorsque nous recrutons
une personne éloignée de l’emploi,
nous avons généralement
une personne hyper motivée
et qui a beaucoup à nous apprendre.
Malek, un réfugié libyen, a mis deux ans
pour traverser trois pays en guerre
avant de nous rejoindre en France.
Je crois qu’il a beaucoup à nous apprendre
sur la ténacité, la volonté,
le courage et, d’une manière générale,
sur la vie.
Nous, nous lui apprenons le métier
de plaquiste et de menuisier.
Ces jeunes s’investissent sans compter
et sont généralement reconnaissants
et fidèles à l’entreprise.
L'entreprise devient alors une famille.
Joseph est décédé en février 2009.
J’étais à ses obsèques au fin fond
de la Bretagne, par un matin d’hiver.
J’ai été étonné et marqué de voir
que la moitié des personnes
était constituée des compagnons
et de l’encadrement.
Joseph avait perdu beaucoup d’amis
lors de sa longue période carcérale.
Joseph comptait pour nous.
Nous comptions pour lui.
Il venait chercher un emploi,
il venait se réinsérer,
mais il venait aussi chercher
une seconde famille.
L’entreprise prend soin
des hommes et des femmes.
Nous leur apportons
une expertise technique.
Nous les accompagnons socialement
et parfois financièrement.
Nous avons accompagné
un jeune réfugié afghan
qui a laissé à Kaboul
sa femme et sa fille.
Au plus chaud de la crise
l’année dernière,
nous avons missionné un avocat
pour l’aider à rapatrier sa famille.
Malheureusement, nous n'avons pas réussi
et sa fille a été tuée par les talibans.
C’est un drame que nous avons partagé
avec beaucoup d’humilité et de fraternité
avec ce compagnon seul en France.
À ce moment, beaucoup de compagnons
ont pris conscience
que nous les aiderions eux aussi
s’ils rencontraient des difficultés.
Les recrutements que nous réalisons
avec ces publics éloignés de l’emploi
donnent du sens à chacun.
Les collaborateurs travaillent la journée
pour gagner leur vie,
et le soir ou le week-end,
ils s’investissent,
font du bénévolat dans des associations.
Aujourd'hui, ils ont trouvé un moyen
de concilier leur travail et du sens.
Et ce sont maintenant les chefs
de chantier qui sont demandeurs
pour accueillir
de nouveaux collaborateurs.
Boris, un réfugié polonais,
va le soir chez son chef de chantier
pour prendre des cours de français.
Il l’aide également
dans ses démarches administratives.
Alors forcément, tout n’est pas facile
et de temps en temps,
c’est un peu plus compliqué.
Nous avons accompagné
deux jeunes, Yaël et Emar,
deux frères syriens de 18 et 19 ans
qui ont quitté l’entreprise
après les deux ans de formation.
Toute l’entreprise s’investit énormément
pour accompagner ces jeunes
et nous avons pris ça comme un échec
de les voir partir.
Il est alors important de rappeler
que la finalité n’est pas d’accueillir
de nouveaux collaborateurs,
mais d’aider une personne à s’insérer.
Et nous pouvons être fiers
d’avoir contribué à leur intégration.
Moi, j’avais la grande fierté d’avoir
une entreprise qui marchait bien
et qui accueillait des publics
éloignés de l’emploi.
Mais je me suis vite rendu compte que
je voyais la paille dans l’œil des autres,
mais pas la poutre dans le mien.
J’acceptais la fragilité des autres,
mais je refusais mes propres fragilités,
mes propres difficultés.
En 2011, nous subissons
la crise de plein fouet.
Nous avons pris quelques décisions
qui se sont révélées dangereuses
et l’entreprise connaît
ses premières difficultés financières.
En parallèle, à titre personnel, mon fils
sort d'une opération grave et importante
qui a soudé la famille, mais nous a
profondément marqués et éprouvés.
Commence alors un combat
contre un adversaire redoutable.
Plus les rounds passent,
plus les coups me fragilisent.
Le soir, tel un boxeur,
je mets une gouttière dans la bouche
pour éviter de me broyer les dents
avec la tension de ma mâchoire.
Premier coup.
Je deviens susceptible, irritable.
Je ne peux plus prendre de décision.
Deuxième coup.
Mon corps ne me répond plus.
Lorsque j’allais au travail,
je n’arrivais pas à dépasser
les 50 km/h sur l’autoroute,
Les camions me doublent en klaxonnant
devant ma conduite dangereuse.
Troisième coup.
Je ne dors plus, je perds mes cheveux.
Quatrième coup.
J'ai un genou à terre.
Je suis proche du KO.
Par fierté ou par honte,
je n’accepte pas ce qui m’arrive.
Je n’accepte pas ma fragilité.
Je n’accepte pas ce burn-out.
Ma souffrance me paraît illégitime
comparée à celle des compagnons.
J’ai alors pris la décision
de ne pas le dire à mes équipes.
J'étais le dirigeant, persuadé que si le
dirigeant tousse, l'entreprise s'enrhume.
Nous avons été formés
à nous battre pour survivre,
à manger les autres
pour ne pas être mangé.
Et moi, j’ai été éduqué
à être un petit garçon fort
qui cache ses fragilités
et masque ses émotions.
L’entreprise est parfois
comparée à une chaîne
dont la résistance est donnée
par le maillon le plus faible.
Je ne voulais pas être celui-là.
Aujourd’hui,
avec l’expérience et le recul,
je pense que nos organisations
sont plus proches d’un système
de neurones interconnectés.
Lorsque l’un d’eux devient défaillant,
les liaisons entre les autres
se renforcent
pour aider le neurone défaillant.
La maturité d’une organisation
s’analyse à sa capacité
à prendre soin des plus faibles,
que ce soit les compagnons
ou le dirigeant.
Alors oui, a posteriori,
je regrette de ne pas avoir
avoué ma fragilité
à mes collaborateurs et mes partenaires.
Je pense qu’en leur
cachant mes difficultés,
je ne leur ai pas permis de grandir.
Contempler sa fragilité
permet de se mettre dans une posture
d’humilité pour accueillir les autres.
C’est une preuve de confiance et d’amitié
que de dire que
nous avons besoin des autres.
Audiard disait : « Bienheureux les fêlés,
car ils laisseront passer la lumière. »
J’aime beaucoup cette citation
car je suis persuadé que ce sont
nos fêlures et nos fragilités
qui nous rendent humains.
Nous vivons dans un monde
qui nous pousse à la compétition.
Il faut être fort et lisse.
L’expérience m’a prouvé que
vivre en masquant ses émotions
est éprouvant et angoissant.
Heureusement, j’étais
particulièrement bien entouré
par les personnes à qui
j’avais avoué ma fragilité.
Je pense à mes amis, je pense à ma femme,
mes enfants et mon frère Nicolas.
Ils m’ont aimé.
Ils m’ont aidé.
Ils m’ont permis d’accepter
de me reconstruire et de rebondir.
Même sorti de ce burn-out,
la situation d’entreprise
est restée très difficile.
J’ai pris la décision en octobre 2014
d’aller au tribunal de commerce
et de mettre l’entreprise
en procédure de sauvegarde,
ce qui me permettait d’étaler
ma dette sur dix ans.
Commence alors un nouveau combat.
Les clients qui perdent confiance
et qui dénoncent leurs contrats,
la banque et le tribunal de commerce
qui me mettent une pression en permanence,
les fournisseurs que
je ne peux plus payer,
qui me menacent et m’insultent.
L'entreprise devient hyper fragile,
hyper vulnérable.
La différence avec mon burn-out est que je
ne pouvais plus masquer cette fragilité.
La fragilité de l’entreprise était
sur la place publique, connue de tous.
J’ai alors découvert la force d’assumer
cette fragilité, de la reconnaître.
Je suis à nouveau sur le ring,
mais cette fois-ci, je ne flanche pas.
Je suis fort.
Fort de la cohésion, fort
de la reconnaissance des autres.
Georges, qui m’avait tendu les mains à
la fin de la première journée de travail,
me les retendait à nouveau et me disait :
« Monsieur Riom,
on ne vous laissera pas tomber,
on va se battre avec vous,
on va remonter l’entreprise. »
L’échec -
La réussite d’une entreprise est
collective, mais l’échec est individuel.
En tout cas, c’est comme ça
que je le ressentais.
Certes, je suis tombé seul.
Mais c’est ensemble que l’on s’est relevé.
J'ai tiré un autre enseignement
de cette période.
Beaucoup de personnes redoutent
d'affronter la fragilité des autres.
On a l’impression
qu’elle est parfois contagieuse.
C’est difficile d’aller voir un ami
qui connaît de grandes difficultés.
On a peur de ne pas trouver
les mots qui construisent
et on a peur d’utiliser
les mots qui détruisent.
Moi, j’ai beaucoup apprécié
les amis qui ont su m’appeler.
Ils m’ont envoyé juste un message
pour me dire qu’ils étaient présents
et qu’ils pensaient à moi.
Nous avons tendance à penser
que pour maximiser les profits,
il faut éviter toute erreur, tout échec,
prendre des décisions par l’informatique
ou l’intelligence artificielle,
au détriment parfois
et souvent de l’humain.
Je suis persuadé que
la finalité de nos entreprises
est de faire grandir les hommes et les
femmes pour qu’ils puissent s’épanouir.
L’humain, avec ses vulnérabilités,
crée des organisations
fortes et résilientes.
La force d’une organisation humaine
repose sur les liens
que nous pouvons créer,
comme les neurones.
Notre économie et nos entreprises
doivent être créateurs de lien
avant d’être créateurs de biens.
Mon équilibre et celui de l’entreprise
reposent sur l’humanité
que nous pouvons créer.
Et je suis persuadé que
l’on peut diriger sans imposer,
écouter sans s’effacer,
grandir sans écraser.
Revenons en 2005 à l’entretien de Joseph.
Ma décision de dire oui m’avait effrayé.
En fait, elle a changé ma vie.
Joseph a été la première étincelle,
le début d’une aventure,
le début d’une ouverture
vers la fragilité des autres.
Assumer et reconnaître sa fragilité
permet de grandir
et de faire grandir les autres.
Les fragilités sont parfois bien cachées.
Derrière la carrure imposante et tatouée,
ou derrière celles de dirigeants,
aux airs confiants et bien habillés.
Qu'importe.
Acceptons-les.
Si un jour vous croisez Joseph
au coin de la rue,
sur le palier de votre porte,
ou à un entretien d’embauche,
tendez vos mains comme Georges
et bousculez vos idées reçues.
(Applaudissements)